the military-political situation in the world
remains difficult in a number of regions the
conflict potential has grown, new
hotbeds of tension have arisen
so serious concern is caused by the
build-up of the
US military group directly within the Russian borders, while
also conducting large-scale
exercises, including unplanned ones, we are extremely
worried that
elements of the global  about the
usa, if this infrastructure
moves on, if the missile system
and the usa and nato appear in ukraine, then their
flight time to moscow will be reduced to
70 minutes, and when deploying hypersonic
weapons, it will be up to five
to us from the most serious challenge to our
security in this regard, as you know,
suggested  for the president of the us to start
negotiations on the development of specific
agreements, sometimes you
wonder why they did it in those
conditions, it’s
not clear, I think that from the euphoria of
connection with the victory in the so-called
cold war or with the so-called
victory, the cold
of the wrong  illiterate incorrect assessments of the
situation at that time and an
illiterate incorrect analysis of
possible options for the development of the situation, but
you testament to other reasons for simple,
Russia stands for equal and indivisible
security throughout the Eurasian
space, of
course, as already noted, if
the clearly aggressive lines of
Western colleagues continue, we will take
adequate response  military technical
measures to react harshly to unfriendly steps
and I want to emphasize that we have
every right to do this
we have every right to act designed to
ensure the security and sovereignty of
Russia what is happening now is
the tension that puts the
north in it is their fault
at every step Russia was forced to
somehow respond to  each sh the situation
constantly worsened worsened
worsened degraded it
guaranteed that today we are in such a
situation when we are forced to decide something,
we cannot allow the development of the
situation about which I said
[applause]